Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here
and in this video, I'm revealing ten characters
Pixar cut from Incredibles 2 who you might
wish had been included in the movie.
If you're joining me for the first time, be
sure to tap the bell to get my new videos
and also leave a comment about the movie for
a chance to win an awesome Funko Pop.
Spoilers ahead, so take care if you've not
seen the film, or add this video to your Watch
Later playlist.
Although we never saw her and only briefly
heard her voice, Frozone's wife Honey was
a huge hit with fans in the first movie, so
much so that that Pixar used her only moment
in the sequel to promote the film in the trailer.
"Where you going asap?"
"You better be back asap!"
Sadly, that's about as much as fans got of
Honey in Incredibles 2 but we could have had
more as she very nearly made it on screen.
The filmmakers said they not only created
a design for Honey, but they also initially
included her in the movie's opening sequence.
Unfortunately, the scene was scrapped as writer-director
Brad Bird felt it didn't fit and the movie
was already too packed, so once again we only
get to hear Honey's voice in the sequel, which
Bird believes is funnier.
It's a real shame that Honey didn't get to
make her on-screen debut as I know many Pixar
fans were hoping she'd make an appearance.
The storyboard of Honey's deleted cameo will
be on the Blu-ray.
And her design was re-used in the movie for
one of the many supers assembled on the yacht
at the end.
Look for the character with pink hair, bluish-coloured
suit and long gloves plus goggles.
When Edna Mode discovers that Elastigirl's
new super-suit was created by a designer called
Alexander Galbaki, she's absolutely furious!
"Elastigirl's super suit is by Galbaki!"
"Explain yourself!"
Now, Galbaki only gets a name-check in the
final film, but originally, Edna's rival super-suit
designer was actually going to appear on screen
in a suit-fitting scene with Elastigirl.
Galbaki's character was meant to deliberately
contrast with Edna as his designs were all
about showing off and drawing attention to
him as a designer rather than focusing on
the needs of the supers he's designing for.
And as if that wasn't enough to get Edna's
blood boiling, his designs even broke her
golden rule.
"No capes!"
Giving Elastigirl a cape that she clearly
didn't like or need.
Some early designs of Helen riding the Elasticycle
show her wearing a cape at the same time.
Wearing capes while close to incredibly fast
spinning objects is clearly something that's
very dangerous, as we saw in the first movie!
A character that many fans would like to have
seen return for the sequel was Kari the babysitter.
Kari's role from the first movie was expanded
when she featured in the short film Jack-Jack
Attack which showed her discovering baby Parr's
superpowers and then having her memory wiped
by Rick Dicker.
And the filmmakers appear to have had a brief
cameo in mind for her in the sequel as concept
art of Kari and her parents appears in the
Art of Incredibles 2 hardback book.
In an earlier version of the movie, Winston
Deavor didn't have a sister, instead he had
a brother called Nelson who was the original
villain.
As the story progressed though, Brad Bird
decided the villain would actually work better
as a female character.
So, the decision was made to scrap Winston's
brother and instead introduce a sister called
Evelyn.
And as a bonus, the team found they were able
to make the relationship between Evelyn and
Helen stronger and more interesting than they
were with Nelson and Elastigirl.
Nelson's design wasn't totally lost though
and he was re-used as the wannabe super He-Lectrix.
And before He-Lectrix, there was originally
a female version of this lightning-powered
super called She-lectric.
She-lectric's design ended up being used for
Evelyn who, as I mentioned, was made the main
villain for the movie.
While we do get lots of new super-powered
characters in the movie, even more supers
were designed for the film but didn't make
the final cut.
For example, Brad Bird mentioned a character
called "Overthink" who was originally going
to be a bigger part of the film but ended
up only appearing very briefly with the international
supers at the end of the movie and who was
never named.
According to Bird, "his power was incredible
mental energy, but he takes time to consider
every single thing, and usually misses his
opportunity to correct whatever the problem
was because there's always one more angle
to explore"!
The whole idea of an overthinking superpower
seems a bit strange as it sounds less of a
superpower and more of a chronic weakness.
I can see the humorous potential but it sounds
like the character might have been a bit too
complicated to get across on screen.
Another secondary superhero that appears in
the outtakes section of the Art of Incredibles
2 book is Cosmosis.
Judging from his name and the many celestial
designs considered for his super-suit, I'd
say he was probably going to have various
powers of cosmic manipulation.
Cosmic powers can endow users with powerful
abilities such as manipulating matter across
space and time, and creating force fields
or portals between locations and dimensions.
Cosmosis could have been on a par with extremely
powerful superheroes like Captain Marvel and
Jean Grey's Phoenix Force.
If Cosmosis was only meant to be a secondary
superhero or a wannabe super like Voyd and
her crew, then I think he was probably cut
from the movie because he might have been
too formidable an opponent for the Incredibles
family and even the extremely over-powered
Jack-Jack.
The filmmakers had yet more ideas for supers
they hoped to introduce in the sequel.
There was Berserkeley, who reminds me a bit
of Batman villain Poison Ivy with the green
mask and leaf-like cape behind her.
And her name suggests she might have some
wild or out-of-control powers.
Shock-N-Awe are a pair of supers and their
name and hairstyles suggest they have some
kind of electrical or lightning powers.
The purplish colours in their hair and glasses
made me think of the Wonder Twins from Super
Friends, however, they don't share similar
powers with that DC duo.
The deleted trio Megaman & Co seem to be the
least developed of the supers design-wise
and look like they're wearing home-made costumes,
so it's possible they were going to be used
more for comic effect than any real threat
to the Incredibles.
Now, do you wish any of these characters had
appeared in the movie?
Be sure to comment and subscribe for a chance
to win a cool Incredibles Funko Pop.
Tap left to check out 10 awesome deleted scenes
from the movie, and tap right for my full
Pixar playlist including easter eggs and all
Jack-Jack's powers explained!
Remember to tap the bell to get all my new
videos as soon as I upload them.
And if you enjoyed this video, a thumbs-up
is always appreciated.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!